this program is brought to you by Emory
University
transplantation today provides our
patients a remarkable benefit they
prolongs their lives restores them to
vitality and health in the 1980s the
results of transplants were poor and
kidneys were lost from rejection and
then we got the cyclosporine class of
drugs and they really revolutionized
transplantation short-term outcomes got
much better we expected most of our
patients to survive with a functioning
graph for ninety percent of them at a
year the problem is that cyclosporine
while it's great for short-term outcomes
causes lots of side effects that really
limit the long-term outcomes that our
patients would would like cyclosporine
is very toxic to the kidney and over
time that can cause scarring and loss of
function and on average are transplants
only survived for about eight to ten
years which is clearly far short of what
you'd like for our patients in addition
cyclosporine causes lots of other side
effects like diabetes perhaps a third of
our patients will develop post
transplant diabetes almost all of them
take blood pressure lowering medications
and most of them take medications to
lower their cholesterol because
cyclosporine causes all those side
effects so the patients will be on any
rejection drugs and then we'll take a
handful of drugs to compact combat the
side effects and all of that leads to
premature death from cardiovascular
disease so there's a tremendous need for
better drugs to prevent rejection but
without causing all those side effects
the problem of rejection is that the
immune system recognizes the transplant
is foreign and lymphocytes T cells
attack and cause immune damage of the
transplant so we need drugs to dampen
the immune system cyclosporine does that
and Bella tacit does that as well the
problem with cyclosporine is it doesn't
just affect the immune response it also
hits a target that's throughout the body
so all of those other targets throughout
the body in the cardiovascular system
caused those side effects of
cyclosporine elit astept is different it
blocks the immune system but it does so
in a selective way because the the
target of Bella tacit is really only
expressed in the immune system so you
can suppress the undesired immune
response of rejection but you won't see
those off target or non the
cardiovascular side effects
bellota Supt has been studied
extensively in kidney transplants and
those are the results that have just
been presented more than 1400 patients
have been studied in kidney transplant
conceptually this drug would also have
advantages for other forms of organ
transplantation and studies are ongoing
for liver transplant and and conceivably
it could be a benefit for for all the
transplants heart long intestinal
transplant
you
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University